i think i'm
new to being vulnerable outside of songs
so it's like like i see a lot of
pictures of me um and there's like
smiles on them and i'm always like it's
just weird though because i didn't feel
good at all that day and i
i kind of
am
sick of smiling on days when i don't
feel like smiling and i feel like this
odd pressure because i don't want
um like my fans to
think that i'm taking something for
granted so if like i accept an award and
i'm like super smiley but behind the
scenes i was really
there was like stuff going on or i
didn't feel i don't know like a lot of
what i do is for other people and i
haven't given myself the
the time to just
accept that it's okay to not be okay so
i i didn't just my whole point is i just
didn't want to bring that into the show
i'd love to talk about funny stuff and
anything that you have for me i would
love to just like i would love to just
get out of what i'm what i'm doing and
like
i don't mean to sound creepy but i like
you so much more
i really do in fact we were just talking
about where different people were from
and someone was like why do you know
utah and i was like i went there to go
change my life and
i just you know i went through a really
painful divorce and i wasn't doing very
well and i just wanted to go talk to
some people and how to
pull myself out of a hole and i had
these two kids that i had to fight for
and um i needed help so i started
reaching out to different people and
eventually i really made some big
sweeping changes in my life
and i got i got on a whole new track not
back on track but a brand new one that i
helped build
[Music]